I saw it yes just across here so you
have to go out to get back up again
yes right here
this is not the hotel this is our north
wing Motel now why in the [ __ ] would
understand they're all we have available
to rent in the hotel or four Suites I'd
rather stay in their next tour okay fun
in this dump
I'm sorry people want to stay in the
hotel they don't want to stay in the
Crackerbox driving up yeah I didn't
expect to be put in a motel no I
understand and I'm sorry alright it's
just right over here thank you you're
welcome
let see how that sofas hideous who would
use a [ __ ] Brown sofa like that oh my
god it gets worse in here as bad as this
aunty I know the rooms are furnished
completely with stuff from Philip and
Ginger's home oh dear there's a mattress
from the house yes you bring a mattress
from your house into your hotel I
wouldn't they charge $250 a night for
that mattress I don't even know what to
say about it when they get new stuff
they bring old stuff here there's some
storage rooms that are furniture where
the storage places well jeez it's like a
suite just for a crib it's like a
dumping ground there's more - wow you
are kidding me
not Oh Mike your heart look at this it
was like a holder just junk everywhere I
don't understand the hotel owner that
would dump half heirship hotel rooms are
not rent them out
Gordon was pretty appalled that the
state of the storage rooms how much crap
there was in there just a big [ __ ]
waste I appreciate it thank you wow this
place is so disappointing Wow okay let
me just have a quick look around and
I'll follow you okay what's all this out
here what is that oh that's just
watering the plants yeah and we get a
lot of hikers and it rains here
sometimes what is that
you know is it in here a long time I
just like Freddy Krueger's have whose is
this it's just there for anybody that
wants to borrow oh I see and does anyone
borrow that they have it yet interesting
these yeah there are there's a sale yes
we did three to twenty three pennies and
this is how much room maybe not more
whatever you an offer
we're very flexible I'm not too sure
that's my style and that's a pretty
special um why is it so special
because it's full of dust yeah with
Virginia and this is almost heaven how
much does that one teach whatever you
offer these secondhand know some things
are but not that is your business how
you selling many are you are you busy no
we don't really sell a lot of hats
I see mm-hmm well you got customers in
already hello this is my friend Sarah
Sarah oh nice to meet you could see join
us for lunch today are you I have no
idea I'm up to whatever I'm here I do
she's family
is this a convenience store or well I
mean it's very claustrophobic and here
is bits and bobs of everything those
freaky dolls we all go for they are sort
of souvenirs oh you selling los we do
mm-hmm
dusty a lot of people come here have
children you're looking for something to
take back all about this one have a
click to his choice how much is this one
I think 25 just I didn't know they were
for sale you didn't know that for sale
how much does this room make a month um
I can't give you an exact figure because
record the purchases in with the
restaurant sales yeah that I would say
in 15% of sales 15% mm-hmm who drinks
all this cider and no actually we use
that in the restaurant geez
well but we sell a lot of it it's good
in the summer June July and August now
my daughter made those well are they a
little hats
children for a dust and hair and what's
this pets
handmade hope hats mm-hmm it's a $60 who
buys this people with children I hope
people with children that's full of dust
inside well you have to wash it before
you use it well what's this this is
Sarah's journal so she keeps a journal
yeah Wow so it's almost like a novel it
is and she puts the sermon notes and
telephone numbers and prices and she
calls it her brain no public bathroom
decorated with baskets yeah she
decorated the baskets I've been in my
washroom oh yeah okay Wow
so alright what's that that that is a
bottle holder you can put like a water
bottle in it so it's stuff I hadn't
thought of that
you've got a point yes that's our bread
and then behind that is the closet where
our potatoes are kept but other loaves
for sale too if someone asks for them
and hackers do some time but normally if
so it's just for the breakfast we have
total are you expecting a lot of people
that's how much we go through in a few
days believe it or not really I'm
fortunate out of date as well
we couldn't are you serious 2nd of
November okay you're right today's the
6:00
oh that's very good
and these 5:30 at 8:05 walking right in
we want to be ready for this place my
god what happened to him he didn't last
very long did he found a cat huh bloody
hell
dead cat the cabbage welcome
nice to meet you always good to see you
too golden first name is Melissa Melissa
good morning how are you Lisa croc Lisa
nice to see you got know very happy I do
is my resting face Wow yes
welcome to the Vienna that's not happy
to be here well I'm sure the cat food
cat got run over I see and you gotta
stuff probably rice actually better to
see you rice I'm yeah love the Attar by
the way thank you everyone wears this
Wow how much are the outfits about 300
$400 $300 3 a ver egde you know they get
their own I mean there are their own
dresses you know oh you buy your own
uniforms yeah stop heads we do oh they
haven't for many years and it reminds
them to not gain weight Wow so who
designed the place well my husband and I
and whose idea was it to buy it for me
um my husband she said wasn't yours it
was not my ideas actually very much
against it Wow why are you against it it
was very overwhelming I had two small
children but probably after I lost my
mind the first year
I think we started to get a hang of it
and whose Austrian are you when husbands
have Austrian or polish right I'm not
nearly as exotic I'm very American right
and he's the chef right so he runs the
restaurant kitchen and you run the inn
correct and whose idea was the violins
on the table mine
where'd that come from that was actually
from an estate sale down the street a
dead man's violin yes why not
I don't assert across the table with my
wife and look at dead man's violin well
bit freaky no no what would you rather
look at when you see the Vienna huh
who's hurt my wife Oh your wife yes but
you have to have something to make up
that white space so what would you
suggest my wife
you're gonna put her on the table that's
what I'm a scandalous I am so [ __ ]
confused dead man's violin what about
some flowers
bloody Hamlet is this place always this
clustered as this and who's that there a
Prussian family of course that was
Friedrich that their family always
murdered yes
well a dead man's violin Murder on the
wall and great story to encourage a nice
warm welcoming dinner oh dear
weapon there damn when did that happen
you know it's been here since I've been
here oh really
hi I'm Marian it's always good to see I
give it nervous I'll check into hotel
the windows are smashed anyway how are
you I'm good thank you
I'm happy to be here bullet holes in
them uh you know they might very well be
I'm not sure what they are
we're two hundred and fifty years old
two new 50 years old what's wrong with
the place I think it's beautiful place
but I think it really just
need some upgrading and which part piece
will help me suddenly not the entrance
with the smashed windows well I think it
could be beautiful
yes been neglected for a while what
happened here that looks much better
Wow dear oh dear just read the wallpaper
the know is fantastic what time is your
honor calling in she might be here I can
tell you love to meet her oh he's
bringing Virender up for Endor hi how
are you good how are you
very liberal nervous just nice glance
what happened there it's been there
since before I bought it
how long we have the hotel 10 years 10
years and you don't think about
replacing it first impressions cost of
all to the door it's it's the original
have you been drinking game 3 did you
run a hotel before we bought this 10
years ago
no never no what would you tear apart
children I do that for 20 years those
were in practice Wow okay 201 I'll see
you shortly
I'm gonna go check in and unpack okay
place is filthy
[Music]